you guys don't even get up just enjoy
your beards it's gonna be a great meal
just curious does anybody know anything
about cooking no pressure just like
cooking a turkey for example says you
need some kind of string trusting
strings don't Schmidt that's a good
turkey tip you got more here's a tip
don't cook Thanksgiving dinner for five
people in 14 hours here's another tip
don't ask a guy out on a first date on
the least sexy holiday in America
a good tip that's Zooey Deschanel you
remember her as Jess in the hit show new
girl now her character didn't seem to
know too much about cooking at the time
but in real life Zooey Deschanel is very
passionate about healthy food good
eating and working to make it more
accessible for all of us that passion
inspired her to help create the app
listen to this guys Maryfield I like the
name which aims to make healthier
options less expensive here's how it
works so you go to the grocery store
store you scan your grocery store
receipt after shopping then you get
rewards for buying items from
maryfield's dozens of partner Brands
which the company has deemed better for
you the app was recently named and this
is a good one a finalist in fast
company's 2022 world-changing ideas
Awards go Zoe Deschanel she joins us
here in studio number one I keep saying
your name because I love your name thank
you you were talking about this morning
I think you have one of the coolest
names Zoe Deschanel yeah so let's talk
about this this healthy eating because I
have two children that are grown they're
potty trained and employed but one thing
I think I didn't do well was food I
don't know how to cook so they were
raised on tater tots fish sticks Chef
Boyardee not really healthy eating you
say when you were pregnant you started
thinking about this kind of thing yeah
exactly um well I was trying to eat
really healthy because I felt like a big
responsibility yes being pregnant I was
like oh my gosh like this food I'm
eating it's like going to the baby I'm
like what am I gonna do so I was trying
to eat healthy I started looking into
like you know everything I was eating
and I I found it was difficult to find
information like information was really
hard to find and and I also found that
it was hard to get it was expensive you
had to go out of your way it wasn't
convenient so that inspired me to start
I started a company called let us grow
yeah and we do these like Farm stands
they're hydroponic systems you can like
grow indoors because I wanted to grow my
own food and I'm a terrible Gardener and
then after we did that that was like 20
of your food you can grow at home but
I'm like what about the other 80 that
you have to go to the store for right so
Mary field was like the solution to that
I was like birds them both exactly I
didn't like that I had the access and
the you know the means to get healthy
food but that other people didn't I'm
like what mother doesn't want to give
their kids healthy food what mother
doesn't want that to be convenient for
her what mother or father doesn't want
that to be affordable and accessible you
know so Maryfield
um has been an amazing experience
because we've had so many people people
reach out to us and say like this is the
diff difference between me being able to
afford this healthy food for my children
for my family and not afford it and so
it works like a coupon but a coupon you
have to have at the checkout because
then you have to like clip it you've got
to go there you got to be like oh today
it's like you know three for a dollar
it's Monday like oh when does it expire
no you just buy merryfield Brands
um with your regular groceries you take
a picture of your receipt it scans like
the receipt and looks for all the
Maryfield Brands which are all vetted
and we have really high standards so
they're all deemed better for you and
the people don't have to pay for the app
it's totally free the app is totally
free you get nothing but rewards yeah so
it's just basically a win-win so it's
after the fact after you bought it yeah
you have a week to scan the receipt and
then it just does all the work for you
and you get points you know how like fun
it is when you're like you're like you
take a trip on a on a plane and you're
like yes I got like gold status it's the
same thing little Victory it's victories
like I love gamifying healthy eating it
just really helps it you know be fun and
then also it helps it be more accessible
you know what people love New Girl New
Girl let's talk about new girl because
Giselle over there over there said you
helped her get through the pandemic
thank you Kyle said tequila helped him
so they're very different audience
and if you combine both as well
a little bit later on but it's taking on
a life of its own now on Netflix that
people are rediscovering the show yeah
it's been so wonderful actually
um a lot of people think it's still on
the air I'm like no we we stopped
shooting the show like you know whatever
five years ago but
um it's it's had a Resurgence it's it's
nice to see that it has longevity and
staying power and you have a podcast
with the co-stars where you guys recap
the episodes yeah so lemorne and Hannah
and I have a podcast and so fun because
the thing I missed most was the
camaraderie with you know my co-stars
and you know with the writers and
everything so we've been able to do that
we get to see each other on Zoom yes you
know play around have fun and interview
people that we you know
um that we had on the show or came and
directed episodes or wrote so it was
it's been really fun to do that it's
called Welcome to our show yeah show
speaking of things that got you through
the pandemic HGTV got me through the
home renovation shows I am a sucker for
them are you familiar with that now you
know anybody open floor plan Tony High
ceilings is what you're looking for my
one uh your boyfriend at three years now
Jonathan Scott one of the Property
Brothers uh you guys have spent two
years living in your own reality TV show
basically it's not being filmed it's
your life yeah you remodeled the house
together we did yeah yeah it would go it
was so much fun you know the thing is
he's done like 500 Renovations or
something so he's really collaborative
and he has certain things that are
really important to him he's like very
very into all the architectural details
and the design and everything and he
kind of like there's certain things I'm
like I love Decor I love like pillows
and like fabrics and wallpapers and he
kind of lets me have my little area so
it's it's really nice because he's
working out very well yeah how many
times a day people come up to you and
start singing a Katy Perry song they
think of Katy Perry you know it doesn't
happen as much anymore but it used to be
like oh my gosh people mix this up all
the time and actually when after she had
her baby
um she asked me to do her video she had
a new song out and she was like I don't
want to shoot the whole video yeah
so I did it and it was really fun so
it's fun to be Katie he appreciate you
and looking forward to Joey all the time
in the season three of physical we're
looking forward to seeing you so I
appreciate you joining us thank you Zoe
de Chanel thank you so much